but first we begin with breaking news
from denmark where police have arrested
one person in connection with the
shooting in the capital copenhagen they
say several people were hit by gunfire
at fields shopping center hundreds of
people escaped the area
live to nadine barber in our london
broadcast center for more nadine we've
been looking at images of people fleeing
the scene and of heavily armed
danish police arriving at the site of
the shooting what more can you tell us
well neve the police are still um saying
that uh several people were hit in the
shooting at this shopping mall known as
fields it's
around eight kilometers seven or eight
kilometers from the center of the danish
capital copenhagen uh and it happened at
around uh
6 30 local
time we understand um there is video on
social media uh we think it was shot
inside the shopping mall showing people
running
in panic screaming and you can hear
several shots being fired
for the duration of the the video that
i've seen which is around 15 seconds or
so really terrifying uh scenes um the
police have arrested one person so far
they say they're not in a position to
comment further on the identity of the
individual that they've arrested but
that was fairly quick now
very soon after the shooting happened
there were
a number of armed police on the scene as
well as a police helicopter
and ambulances paramedics there very
quickly as well i've seen at least one
person being taken away by paramedics on
a stretcher we don't know the condition
of the people or in fact how many people
were hit uh during the shooting um this
was really a shocking event for many
people in denmark they might well have
known the place it's a huge shopping
mall extremely popular and not only that
it's just down the road just over half a
kilometer from the royal arena in
copenhagen where the pop star harry
styles was giving a concert in fact he
is giving a concert on sunday night it
was about an hour and a half before that
was due to get underway there was um
speculation that might be affected but
the organizers there are saying no
they're in touch with the police uh
handling the incident around the mall
they are happy for that uh concert to
carry on but it's raised um a lot of
worries for people in the danish capital
uh hundreds of people were believed to
be in or around them all at the time
shopping perhaps grabbing some food and
yeah it's a it's a popular place for
people to relax we don't have any more
information from the police right now
they say they will be updating as they
as they're able to do so and nadine very
briefly i appreciate this is a
developing story but do we have any more
information about the arrest
no the police are stressing
in their only communication so far since
it that they can't say any more about
the person's identity so we don't know
whether it's the shooter or not there is
speculation on social media that the uh
the actual shooter might still be at
large now uh certain um consequences
have followed the uh the royal family
have uh cancelled an event on sunday
evening to do with the tour de france
now the first stage of that uh as part
of the grande park has actually happened
on sunday in copenhagen but the royal
family can sing an event the mayor of
the city uh saying that the incident is
very serious and apparently just a while
ago ambulances were still arriving on
the scene
and um it's being reported that there is
a huge police presence generally around
the city uh indicating uh a manhunt
still underway um the um
so as i say the concerts just down the
road at the royal arena not affected
although people going heading towards
that were worried by it in fact quite a
number of people staying in a hotel for
the concert that was near the shopping
mall actually had to be rushed to safety
after the shooting but they're all okay
thankfully nadine barber on the shooting
in copenhagen uh speaking to us from the
london broadcast centre